Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, You can call the
voicemail number any time of day, and many people
do. Here is a caller suggesting, you know, David,
maybe you're better looking off camera.
Maybe it's not really that bad. Take a
listen to this.
Speaker 5:
So I was thinking your father's like television
world. So when somebody is not, like, really great
on television, like in real life, maybe you're
like, better looking than you are on camera.
Speaker 1: I don't know why I find this so funny.
Speaker 5: I noticed a lot of people are. And,
you know, I feel like there's something against
people who just aren't good on camera. Yeah. And
it's frustrating. Nobody holding you accountable.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, you should look at
my inbox. There are many people holding me
accountable for my physical appearance. You
should see men. Many of those people are peddling
an anti-Semitic commentary about my appearance,
which I will not indulge anymore, specifically
right now. But no, no, no. Plenty of people are
holding me accountable for my physical appearance.
Rest assured, if you were concerned, we have a
great bonus show for you today. We talked at the
top of the podcast about Democrats saying Dianne
Feinstein should resign. We are going to talk
on the bonus show about Republicans lining up
to say Dianne Feinstein should not be replaced
on the Judiciary Committee. This is a big issue.
It's becoming a huge flashpoint in Joe Biden's
first term and judicial nominations. Secondly,
we are going to talk about the Supreme
Court and the potential restoration of
religious liberty in the workplace. Those sound
like dangerous buzzwords, don't they? Yes,
absolutely they are. And George Anthony Devil,
Older Santos has announced he's running for
reelection to serve the people of the. What is
that? The third District of New York, I believe.
Why is he doing it? Does he have a
shot? What the hell is going on with
this guy? We will talk about all of these
stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: We're going to try to make some
money on the bonus show. Join us by signing up
at. Join Pacman dot com. I will see you then.